so I wanted to try the Nvidia broadcast
eye contact beta where
wow and AI is making it look like I am
looking at you even though I'm not there
might be a few frames where you can see
that I'm actually staring at the screen
um it's basically faking my eyes to make
it look like they're looking at the
camera at all times it is in beta okay
but I find this very creepy
I'm threatened by myself right now I
feel like I'm I look like I'm going to
kill me
nobody makes this much eye contact
wait
and beta there are totally uses for this
doing ad reads where you don't want to
like look at a camera I'm sure this is
like it's useful for loads of influences
I can see use cases for me right now I'm
just terrified